friends fans brace yourself
Jennifer Aniston isn't shutting down the
idea of a reunion anything is a
possibility Ellen
the actress stopped by The Ellen
DeGeneres Show on Friday that's the song
yeah what song
what something fun you still do that
clap Wow and when the talk show host
asked Aniston if her and her cast mates
from the hit NBC sitcom would ever
consider a reboot she kept her answer
open-ended anything is a possibility
Ellen okay anything yes yes she goes I
mean George Clooney got married like
that's here can happen and while fans
may have to wait to see if Ross Rachel
Joey Phoebe Monica and Chandler meet up
at Central Perk again there have been
several many cast reunions off screens
in 2016 Matthew Perry and Matt LeBlanc
were working on separate projects on the
same studio lot and dish to ET about
bumping into each other see Maddie I've
already bumped in them twice it's great
to see him there and it's a you know
it's funny to see him on us on a lot and
not like run lines with her you know
it's just strange you know it's like
what Seenu you why are you out here to
be no no no no you're on a different
show now that's 20 years ago never mind